bonsoir à tous nous sommes le jeudi 19
mai merci de nous retrouver pour cette
nouvelle édition du 7 8 le journal comme
chaque jour nous revenons sur votre
actualité locale entouré de nos invités
mais également des journalistes de la
rédaction tout de suite les titres de
cette édition
bientôt tous en autolib le service de
location de voitures électriques s'étend
dans le département après le chesnay et
vélizy les voitures arrivent à
versailles le point dans cette édition
tintin mars est un projet d'habitat
participatif menée en association avec
la commune de là derrière dans le cadre
des portes ouvertes européenne de
l'habitat participatif samedi 21 mai à
la verrière le projet sera présenté aux
habitants
romulus akinocho membres du collectif
associatif tintamarre nous on parlera ce
soir et enfin les nouveaux nés sont de
sortie à thoiry comme chaque année le
zoo accueille de nouveaux petits
pensionnaires nous vous les présenterons
et pour commencer cette information les
rassemblements contre la loi travail
continu une nouvelle journée d'action
était organisée aujourd'hui les
transports sont concernés la culture
aussi ce matin le château de versailles
a ouvert ses portes à 10 heures et demie
au lieu de 9 heures habituellement après
un préavis de grève de l'intersyndicale
à 11 heures la cgt culture du château
annoncé 35 % de grévistes au niveau de
la surveillance du musée
seuls les grands appartements ou ouvert
au public pour le château les jardins et
le domaine de marie antoinette était
ouvert normalement
les grévistes ont ensuite rejoint le
cortège parisien écoutez ces précisions
recueillies par mélanie pottier c'est
déjà un très haut niveau de mobilisation
avec le confort puisque grande partie de
l'établissement est fermé
vous venez aujourd'hui vous verrez pas
grand chose les régressions sociales ne
s'arrête pas s'arrête jamais aux portes
du privé elle s'applique souvent aussi
avec rebond à la façon d'une lettre tous
les cafés en fait en matière de droit du
travail
on le retrouve café chez nous
agriculture à présent cet après midi
à l'ancienne se tenait la soixante
douzième assemblée générale de la fdsea
les membres de la fédération
départementale des syndicats
d'exploitants agricoles sont revenus sur
leurs actions et leur travail mené au
quotidien l'occasion également
d'interpeller une nouvelle fois le
gouvernement sur la crise des
agriculteurs et leurs problématiques
williams elle pour ce reportage
c'est un profond désarroi qui
caractérise l'état d'esprit des
agriculteurs français aujourd'hui ce 19
mai la fdsea organisé sa 72e assemblée
générale permettant un état des lieux
des travaux du syndicat mais aussi de
mettre à jour les problématiques
rencontrées par les agriculteurs
il ya une absence de revenus les
agriculteurs aujourd'hui est souvent ces
agriculteurs céréaliers qu'on stigmatise
de nantis et s'est régulièrement ne
vivent plus de leur métier
c'est à dire que on a une majorité de
nos exploitants en ile-de-france qui ne
gagnent pas leur vie depuis un an et
demi deux ans parce qu'en fait les cours
sont très bas et les charges ont très
très hot dans le viseur la sueur
administrations françaises et des
agriculteurs qui se sentent abandonnés
par leur ministère concernant les
retards de paiement mais l'assemblée
générale est aussi l'occasion de faire
le point sur les avancées réalisées en
matière d'environnement
il ya des changements sur la politique
des nitrates ya des changements sur la
boutique des produits phytosanitaires
avec un certain nombre de bonnes
pratiques que l'on a pu écrire pour
protéger les abeilles pour avancer sur
la communication est sûr essayer de
faire mieux comprendre notre métier
aujourd'hui à beaucoup d'interrogations
et on doit y répondre et on y répond au
menu également des problématiques plus
locales comme l'installation des gens du
voyage sur des parcelles agricoles dans
les yvelines
ici la fdsea interpelle directement la
préfecture ou encore l'installation d'un
supermarché à gagny et difficulté
aujourd'hui bas
dans les yvelines problème de foncier
donc avec l'agrandissement de toutes les
les villes et les contraintes les
infrastructures urbaines etc après les
difficultés sur un marché mondial ne pas
avoir les mêmes normes de peut être même
hauteur que peu de pays comme
l'allemagne l'espagne les gros problèmes
qu'on rencontre actuellement bc
lustremant c'est la ligne npn paris
normandie qui sont le projet continua à
se peaufiner et le gros souci est que
nous personnellement on n'en veut pas
puisque les pas question d'avoir de la
nouvelle emprise sur nos territoires
selon la fdsea le poids des normes
seraient une entrave à la compétitivité
de la france en matière d'agriculture
la crise agricole principal sujet de
cette journée risque de rester encore
longtemps sur le tapis et je vous le
disais en titre les autolib s'implante
de plus en plus dans les yvelines après
le chesnay et vélizy en 2015 versailles
a accueilli ses premières véhicule du
syndicat autolib à la fin du mois
d'avril trois stations sont déjà
présentes dans la commune yvelinoise
d'autres communes de l'agglomération
versailles grand parc vont elles aussi
proposé des stations d'autopartage
électrique les précisions de mélanie
police
cette borne et véhicules à deux pas de
la mairie tout près de la gare de
versailles rive gauche depuis la fin du
mois d'avril la commune possède 21
véhicules répartis sur trois stations ça
fonctionne très bien parce que le
démarrage en quinze jours trois semaines
on a déjà plus de 160 abonnés annuels
c'est un très très bon complément de
mobilité avec les bus avec la bicyclette
avec la marche à pied pour les
versaillais qui était très demandeur de
ce mode de déplacement entre paris et
versailles et d'autres villes de la
région parisienne dans le courant de
l'année viendront s'ajouter celles de
versailles chantiers et satori quatre
autres stations sont à l'étude
elle devrait voir le jour courant 2010
est à bois d'arcy l'installation est
encore au stade de projet de station
devrait voir le jour à la zone
d'activités de la croix bonnet et près
de l'avenue paul vaillant couturier
grandes artères de la commune
c'est un vrai complément de transport
pour les artisiens mais aussi
du point de vue développement durable
puisque les stations seront équipées de
bornes de rechargement et donc du coup
les artisiens pour des véhicules
électriques pourront prendre un
abonnement autolib et recharger leurs
véhicules sur ces bornes de versailles
grand parc finance les installations à
hauteur de 50% avec le chesnay et vélizy
qui propose déjà ce service
cette agglomération possède pour le
moment très station et nous avons parlé
habitat participatif ce soir avec nos
hauts plateaux et romulus acino de show
membres du collectif tintamarre on sera
vous merci d'avoir accepté notre
invitation alors revenons sur l'habitat
participatif il est apparu en france
dans les années 1970 de paris à toulouse
on recense aujourd'hui en france environ
400 groupes d'habitat participatif et
vous allez vous en dire un peu plus donc
samedi 21 mai à l'occasion des journées
européennes de l'habitat participatif
vous organisez donc avec tout le
collectif à la verrière une journée
portes ouvertes donc dû 10h30 à 17h30
pour faire découvrir le projet de la
mare c'est un projet qui est né en 2014
pour construire un habitable
participatif alors tout d'abord tardif
pour être un habitat participatif c'est
surtout être acteur de son habitat donc
en général lorsqu'on veut accéder à un
logement va visiter on regarde ça nous
convient il ya ce moment là on achète
là on est en amont du projet c'est à
dire qu'on a la possibilité de voir tous
les détails participé à la construction
et comment être comment définir son chez
soi
je vais avoir une chambre plus grande
sincérité petty enfin selon bon salon
chaque personne seulement sur son mobile
alors le projet de la mare c'est ainsi
qu'il s'appelle c'est à la verrière
comment il sortit tu combien de
personnes vous êtes si le et bergers est
ce que oui bien sûr on fait le projet
qui s'articule
l'objectif c'est d'avoir quatorze
ophélie quatorze foyers donc
actuellement nous sommes cette famille
donc justement le les portes ouvertes
c'est la possibilité de présenter le
projet à de nouvelles familles qui
seraient éventuellement intéressés à
découvrir et à faire un achat dans le
participative tout simplement et donc le
projet il s'est donc plutôt
l'association et a été chapeautée par
quoi de conseils qui nous a accompagnés
tout au long parlant de moi quand je
suis arrivé je ne connaissais absolument
rien à l'habitat participatif donc j'ai
tout découvert et tout appris avec eux
au fur et à mesure donc voilà alors
c'est un projet qui est né aussi avec la
mairie qui vous accompagnent dessus ça
s'articule comment par rapport à ça
c'est la mairie qui donne le terrain et
après c'est exactement pas
d'instructions exactement donc l'idée
c'est la mairie qui qui lui a proposé
les initiateurs du projet qui propose le
terrain magnifique qui s'est juste en
face d'un parc qui a gardé l'aspect
sauvage
ensuite nous enfin le choix
l'association avait le choix de faire
appel à un bailleur social pour avoir
laissé un peu plus solides
financièrement sur la finalité du projet
et donc donc normalement donc fin de fin
de cette année il y avoir une promesse
de vente entre la mairie et les copies
mot qui est le bailleur social et
ensuite à ce moment là il y aura le
lancement le permis de construction et
l'objectif justement c'est d'avoir les
clés pour début 2010 8 d'accor
si on résume voilà vous choisissez avec
ti vous
vivre ensemble le terrain l'architecte
également voilà tout à fait donc on est
il ya eu on a rencontré plusieurs ans
jacques schutte et architectes aux six
architectes
il ya eu un concours et donc on le gagne
en est le projet que vous avez pu voir
et donc l'idée effectivement c'est
d'avoir un chacun son chez soi dans
l'habitat participatif
voilà c'est pas une comité mais on
partage des lieux par exemple on va
avoir une salle commune on peut partager
une buanderie
mais voilà c'est il ya cet aspect
collectif mais il ya aussi chacun son
chez soi
voilà vous allez voilà prendre aussi
voilà un appartement dans cet habitat
participatif dans cette aventure
en fait tout simplement moi je ne
connaissais pas du tout c'est ma
compagne en fait qui m'a amené là une
présentation de réunions donc moi j'ai
écouté dans un premier temps et fur et à
mesure l'idée m'a plu parce que le
concept c'est quand même d'être on
repart sur le être citoyen du monde
c'est à dire qu'on part vers un habitat
plus écologique
donc c'est là on fait attention plus
économique aussi puisque l'idée aussi
c'est au niveau de l'énergie la volonté
c'est d'avoir une facture moindre au
niveau de l'énergie en même temps quand
on voit le actuellement ce qui se passe
dans le monde
c'est c'est pas plus mal il ya un aspect
aussi solidarité intergénérationnelle
parce que voilà pouvoir vous êtes assez
jeune pour fait partie ce problème il ya
des personnes âgées également tout à
fait donc bien être des personnes
retraitées
donc c'est reis et multi génère
intergénérationnel effectivement est
aussi multi social c'est le but parce
que on va s'enrichir les expériences des
uns et des autres par exemple chez un
jeune père et moi dans l'idée c'est
effectivement il ya des partis qui sont
plus âgés
j'aimerais le faire j'ai pas mes
grands-parents avec moi j'aimerais
qu'ils puissent avoir l'expérience de
personnes plus âgées
non bon dans le quotidien alors donc il
ya de la mixité sociale sociologique moi
aussi c'est un avantage économique il
était certain effectivement parce
qu'effectivement on part dans l'idée de
de partager les les fondent donc on part
sur effectivement certains lieux qui
sont partagés donc ok là chacun va
participer financièrement donc ça permet
donc le l'habitat participatif ça peut
être effectivement la salle connu pour
les fêtes donc après c'est juste au
niveau de l'association un travail à
faire entre nous pour émettre des règles
un règlement intérieur une charte que
que tout le monde va adhérer
et voilà enfin de vivre dans une
convivialité
comment les familles sont choisis est ce
qu'il ya un dossier à déposer est-ce
qu'il faut respecter je ne sais pas
peut-être à certains critères
ah non le nous le principalement le
critère principal c'est l'adopter la
vision la vision qui représente
l'habitat participatif donc c'est la
possible et découvrir ses voisins en
fait c'est vrai que souvent quand on
arrive en connais pas ses voisins on
arrive dans un appartement
l'idée là effectivement c'est d'avoir de
connaître ses voisins déjà d'échanger
avec eux de se mettre d'accord sur la
manière dont on veut vivre ensemble
c'est un vivre autrement vivre ensemble
et autrement
alors donc les prochaines étapes du
poulet donc là samedi
samedi 21 mai donc les familles qui sont
intéressées peuvent venir pour plus
d'informations et après dumont qui a
toutes les familles donc c'est une
dizaine d'épisodes de famille 14 à 17
ans famille voilà donc ces c'est une
fois qu'on a les quatorze familles c'est
en fait nous ont préféré idéalement
parce que on arrive à une un moment
charnière du projet donc elle
effectivement vous avez vu la
présentation du projet maintenant
choisir comment on va être son
appartement
c'est idéal pour les personnes d'arriver
à ce moment là pour pouvoir avoir aussi
leur avis sur le projet définitif et ça
se passe bien ou 2018 la construction
commencée voilà parfait et bien si vous
avez 18 ans vont quitter plus vite on
rentrait donc ça va c'est assez rapide
en tout cas merci beaucoup d'être venus
sont pas tous et de nous en avoir parlé
alors je le rappelle donc samedi 21 mai
à l'occasion des journées européennes de
l'habitat participatif
vous organisez la verrière une journée
porte ouverte de 10h30 à 17h30 si vous
voulez plus d'information n'hésitez pas
allez sur le site internet www.steria.fr
qui s'affiche en bas de votre écran
merci à vous fois et on prend à présent
la direction du zoo de thoiry nous
allons parler nouveau-né le printemps
rime avec naissance pour le parc
cette année les quatre cent mille
visiteurs annuels pour observer des
bébés où elle habitait ouistiti les oryx
d'arabie des lémuriens ou encore des
zèbres
mais qu'elle allume hydro a eu la chance
d'aller saluer ces nouveaux venus
regarder la famille touahri s'agrandit
le parc zoologique yvelinois qui recense
plus de 800 animaux et 120 espèces
enregistré 37 naissances en 2016 dont
une dizaine depuis le début du mois de
mai on essaie aussi de faire en sorte
que les naissances arrive à un moment où
c'est aussi le plus facile pour la
survie du petit c'est à dire qu'un petit
petites antilopes qui va naître en plein
hiver quand il fait moins dix ses
chances de survie sont un petit peu plus
faible que si il est né maintenant et
que ben il a tout l'été pour devenir un
peu plus fort et donc aborder l'hiver un
peu plus facilement évidemment ça
coïncide avec la période où le public
est là on va pas s'en plaindre
c'est forcément plus intéressant pour un
visiteur de voir de voir des animaux des
bébés cette année les quatre cent mille
visiteurs annuels pourront observer des
bébés wallaby des ouistitis des zèbres
des bises ou encore des oryx d'arabie
cacher le plus souvent dans les pattes
de leur mère
ces naissances sont toujours bien
accueillis par les 60 employés du parc
c'est pas forcément un critère de que
l'animal est bien parce que les animaux
c'est ça fait partie de leur vie de se
reproduire
donc voilà les autres animaux vous
mettez un mal une semaine globalement
souvent ça va se reproduire mais
évidemment quelle que soit la naissance
on est content donc là quand on a des
petits des petits du goût des petits
chevaux des petits trucs comme ça c'est
oui forcément on est content de
nouvelles naissances devraient avoir
lieu dans les prochaines semaines chez
les zèbres les antilopes et légumes où
chaque année le parc accueille entre 70
et 80 nouveaux pensionnaires du sport à
présent cinquante sportifs de haut
niveau étaient dans les yvelines ce
mardi les athlètes ont participé à la
24e édition du tibre est qu au golf de
la queue-lez-yvelines alors comme tous
les ans les joueurs se sont affrontés
dans une partie de golf avant de passer
quelques minutes avec des enfants venus
de trappes et de versailles dans la
soirée une vente aux enchères était
organisée au profit de sos gaz l on
écoute l'organisatrice véronique chaplin
l est est au micro de michael bay drew
tu es vraiment des choses collector et
l'ensemble de l'argent pas permettre de
financer 200 trains en ile-de-france et
en au sénégal laurent blanc nous a porté
le maillot de verra-t-il le maillot de
l'équipe du psg signé de tuzla thann et
c'est le ballon nous avons la raquette
de yannick noah la raquette les règles
quatre raquettes des quatre finalistes
de coupe davis
nous avons la veste de philippe
candeloro nous avons pas d des prêts des
choses très prestigieuse et nous
recevons à présent sur ce plateau notre
journaliste sportif mitel et demi
d'euros pour sa chronique sport du jeu
dit bonsoir michael assure florane alors
je tenais réagir par rapport au tiebreak
a eu lui reproche il vient de passer
j'ai tenté de vous acheter le maillot du
psg signé par tous les joueurs du psg
mais malheureusement c'était un petit
peu de budget pour moi est ce qu'on me
pardonne et je vous parle d'elle mais
qu'elle s'était quand même gentil et
leurs pensées m'ont rejoint notre
chronique alors aujourd'hui vous allez
nous présenter les rendez vous à ne pas
manquer ce week end alors je ne peux
rien vous cacher il y aura énormément de
rendez vous importants ce week-end dans
les yvelines pour ne pas boire la tasse
ou toutes ces informations je vous
conseille de retenir votre souffle
on commence par de l'apnée a encore
risque de tomber à la piscine municipale
de saint cyr l'école ce dimanche 22 mai
andy cabreira avis à un appelé mise à
ban apnéistes de 45 ans d'origine
cubaine va tenter de parcourir la plus
grande distance possible en apnée
pendant six heures pour
sportif devrait effacer le record de
pascal maes et le français effectués 9,3
km le 7 février dernier pour le battre
andy s'entraîne au minimum deux fois par
semaine depuis trois mois c'est un
effort intense l'épreuve la plus
difficile c'est la gestion de l'effort
aura pas au cra l'année un fort effet
six heures j'ai beaucoup malgré les
vagues et je m'hydrate tous les 30
minutes
je m'arrête pour une minute et ses
déboires mais là tu es avec des roses ou
collègues dé l'eau des sels minéraux
pourquoi s'est-il lancé ce défi fou une
telle alors c'est un record pour la
bonne cause florane chaque longueur
effectué par andy permettra de récolter
1 euro pour financer un exosquelette
pour aider luna une enfant de 10 ans
victime d'une infirmité motrice
cérébrale
la combinaison pourrait lui permet de se
déplacer en écoute et en combinaisons
que coûte 6000 euros
côté social cette combinaison permet aux
handicapés d améliorer leur motricité
donc elle accouchait luna c'est mon
élève c'est une copine l'égard des
magnifiques
donc si difficile d'accorder des pascal
maes et mais par l'imo pour n'importe
quoi c'est qu'on cause c'est les enfants
handicapés gamme et des rancoeurs est
une belle cause vous pensez qu'il peut
réussir ce défi média j'en suis persuadé
florane pendant ses séances
d'entraînement andy a réalisé la même
distance que le précédent record en
seulement trois heures et 13 minutes
autant dire qu'il a toutes les chances
pour battre ce record fraude il sera
d'ailleurs à l'invité du suite du 7-8
sport que vous présenter lundi prochain
à 10h30 en exclusivité on continue
maintenant par de cyclisme sur piste les
amateurs de vélo de vrai sprinter ce
week-end pour aller au vélodrome de 50
ans niveau le temple du cyclisme
français sur une nouvelle fois le
théâtre d'une compétition de haut niveau
ce week-end la coupe de france fenioux
et pour dames et de ce vendredi 20 mai à
ce beau samedi 21 mai au programme une
cinquantaine de courses
les amateurs pourront voir de la vitesse
dames et hommes de la poursuite des
courses aux points du scratch des
époques d'omnium au total 18 nations
sont représentées plus de 100
participants vont s'affronter parmi les
têtes d'affiché on retrouvera la
française lorie berton vice-champion du
monde 2016
l'anglais à jason kenny triple champion
olympique mais est égal mais aussi
grégory baugé neuf fois champion du
monde
un beau plateau on écoute le pistard de
lille
de france françois pervis est un beau
plateau
bon bah nous il ya toute l'équipe de
france déjà et puis ensuite les
étrangers vous allez y à des polonais
qui on marchait très fort tous tout cet
hiver
et puis aussi surtout le champion du
monde et champion olympique jason kenny
langue est donc ça va être intéressant
de voir lui aussi ou est ce qu'il en est
du c'est un petit test mais
on va pas en tirer de grandes de grandes
conclusions c'est juste pour voir où est
ce qu'on en est actuellement et pour
pour gérer au mieux la suite du
programme d'entraînement si vous voulez
réserver vos places c'est 10 euros à la
journée 15 euros pour les deux jours et
gratuit pour les moins de 12 ans il
reste quelques places en tribune florane
si l'envié vous prend d'aller voir du
cyclisme sur piste il reste quelques
places je suis pas très long mais j'ai
quand même à me renseigner si l on
continue cette chronique par du football
et plus précisément par le championnat
de division d'honneur versailles ne
devra pas se manquer ce week-end les
versaillais deuxième du classement de dh
reçoivent les murs au troisième du
classement ce dimanche à 15 heures au
stade de montmoreau le match est capital
dans la course à la montée vers cei ne
compte que trois petits points de retard
sur le premier créteil lusitanos après
son incroyable série de six victoires
consécutives
je vous rappelle que seul le premier du
classement montera en cfa la saison
prochaine et ce n'est pas encore fini on
termine par du basket là aussi le match
sera capital dans la course à la montée
en saura plus où donner de la tête 1
dans les yvelines ce week end le
chesnay-versailles joue ce match si
important le match des play off de
nationale 3 pour savoir si oui ou non
l'équipe va monter en nationale 2 à
l'année prochaine
dernier match ce dimanche à 15h30 les
yvelinoises reçoivent escaudain au
gymnase bel air l'équipe qui les avait
battus à 85 à 59 au match aller en cas
de victoire le ch ine retrouverez la
nationale 2 un an après l'avoir quittée
se seront belles histoires toutes belles
histoires forme un happy end comme miles
michael merci à vous on se retrouve la
semaine prochaine semaine prochaine je
bloque pour jeudi comme d'habitude très
bien mon reste avec moi je vous emmène à
cannes tout de suite troisième épisode
de notre série consacrée aux yvelinois
présent au festival direction la
croisette et ses coulisses aujourd'hui
nous avons suivi le directeur de cinéma
des longs cours un ancien étudiant de 3e
de trappes et nous avons rencontré
également franck provost le coiffeur des
stars il a débuté sa carrière dans notre
département
khanal 60 18 c'est signé alexis garneau
grigori canale et nicolas kirilow vie de
se regarder
bienvenue à cannes on vous emmène dans
les coulisses du festival à strass
paillettes soirée à cannes de nombreux
professionnels viennent surtout faire du
business et des rencontres c'est le cas
de l'ubs beau quand le directeur du ciné
c est à elancourt le marché du film de
cannes est l'un des événements les plus
importants de l'industrie
cinématographique avec +2 10 mille
professionnels ici des producteurs des
distributeurs des vendeurs et des
programmateurs de festivals et que tes
films on trouve de tout à cannes le
meilleur comme le pire du blue
classiques aux plus surprenant le marché
du film c'est vraiment pour le
distributeur en fait les producteurs les
distributeurs
ils vont les films à l'international
c'est intéressant mais il projette aussi
des films
donc on va accéder fois de temps en
temps on peut réussir à choper si je
puis dire une invitation pour aller voir
un film ou deux mais c'est quand même
assez rare ont marché du film ya tout il
ya un peu de tout et n'importe quoi
enfin ça c'est normal il ya tous les
gens du cru or la série z la série b et
c ses draps par contre dans les
sélections officielles on va dire que ce
soit à quinzaine acide enfin etc je vais
pas toutes les citer il ya quand même
plutôt du bon voire du très très bon on
voit le maximum de films c'est vachement
important pour nous parce qu'on a
exploitant parce qu'on a assez peu le
temps de voir les films en amont dans
l'année parce qu on est tout le temps en
train de courir après la la mécanique si
je puis dire
les projections de presse à paris en a
quelques unes on arrive à y aller mais
pas toujours ces deux blocs une demi
journée voire une journée
on n'a pas toujours le temps donc cannes
c'est vraiment loverdos si je puis dire
de deux films on les enchaîne on les
voit et on l'est on prend des notes
et ensuite quand on les a aimés on les
programme et on les défend c'est ça qui
est important
cannes c'est également une chance pour
les plus jeunes de se faire un nom dans
le métier ou le royer est un ancien
élève des trois yes l'institut
international de l'image et du son de
trappes il n'a que 21 ans et déjà de
nombreux projets en tête cette année il
est venu à cannes pour travailler aux
côtés d'une attachée de presse
mais légalement emmené avec lui son
dernier court-métrage triangle une
histoire d'amour pourquoi ce film
ça va partir d'un constat très simple
c'est mon film de fin d'études donc il
fallait que je livre 1
une idée un film à telle date je savais
qu'on allait tourner ça en 3e année
notre site de fin d'études et j'ai
cherché des idées et oui en fait
finalement je me suis monsieur rabattu
abattu cet album et je me suis ici j'ai
parlé d'une expérience personnelle et à
partir de là ce qui était rigolo c'était
de prendre quelque chose que j'avais
plus ou moins vécu et de faire joujou
avec et puis d'en faire un film et puis
changer tous les éléments de départ mais
voilà c'est peut-être que barça avait
peut-être aussi envie de parler de moi
et c'est peut-être le plus simple si
parler de ce qu'on connaît pour s'amuser
avec
moi depuis depuis tout petit je regarde
le festival avec avec nommé par an à la
télé c'était un peu un rêve de gosse et
et c'est vrai que à la télé ya tout le
côté paillettes et à tricoter comme ça
et en fait on se rend compte que quand
on est là les gens ne font que parler de
cinéma et c'est un côté beaucoup plus je
sais pas comment dire peut-être un peu
familial mais il ya un vrai côté on est
tous ensemble je sais pas combien on est
sur le festival mais c'est énorme tout
ça une petite accréditation c'est tout
sans se reconnaît dans la rue on sait
qu'on fait partie du festival est en
fait je trouve que j'avais fait des
belles rencontres et on discute avec
plein de gens et en fait on parle que de
signer au mondial ce que tu as vu tel
film at-elle sélection à celui-là il est
super as tu l'as vu un machin on discute
en fait on sait chanter place aussi pour
essayer d'aller au célèbre montée des
marches et jose comme ça c'est de la
bidouille et c'est vraiment dix jours
dans une bulle ciné vous pourrait se
passer un truc à paris qu on ne serait
même pas c'est ça c'est ça la magie et
on se quitte avec une autre star du jour
le coiffeur franck provost c'est dans
les yvelines à saint germes en les kilos
vers son premier salon en 1975 et chaque
année à cannes avec ses équipes de
coiffure et de maquilleurs et le sublime
les stars qui montent les marches pour
un résultat souvent en plein de magie et
de glamour un réel plaisir de devenir
mais effectivement on est là déjà pour
travailler et c'est pas vraiment
travaille beaucoup et quand je savais
des coiffeurs on va coiffer d'une de on
est basé nouveau martinez mais on va se
déplace dans tous les hôtels et ça veut
dire que des coiffeurs sans arrêt ils
font la navette sur la croisette avec
leurs valises et tout et je peux vous
garantir que les valises ça pèse parce
que on
transportent les lacs les produits les
les épingles et où donc quand ils ont
fait ça ça arrive qu'on commence des
journées à 8 heures le matin pour des
photos et souvent à 23 heures ça se
termine donc c'est un vrai havre est de
challans mais en même temps il ya une
espèce de de dynamisme de 2 for i de la
part de tout le monde donc finalement on
oublie la fatigue quoi parce que ici à
il se passe quelque chose c'est magique
quoi ya pas de se trouve pas d'autres
mots que pour qualifier les cannes
cannes c'est magique
418 c'est tout pour aujourd'hui et
n'oubliez pas comme le dit jean luc
godard la télévision fabrique de l'oubli
le cinéma fabrique des souvenirs
et c'est à présent la fin de ce journal
merci de nous avoir suivis demain
nouvelle édition du journal de fin de
semaine avec l essentiel de lecture
présenté par un goût de friedrich y vous
idées sorties et loisirs ce serait avec
michael elle me d'euros dans le site 8e
week-end quant à moi je vous retrouve
lundi pour le journal je vous souhaite
donc une bonne soirée et un excellent
week-end